okay coca-cola lost four billion dollars
in a market value after soccer
star cristiano ronaldo suggested people
drink
water is what he said okay so the soccer
superstar christine ritallo gestures at
euro 2020 press conference on monday
wiped 4 billion off of coca-cola's
market value ronaldo's ahead of his
team's match by the way this is all he
did
he literally just went like this no no
coca-cola
drink water that's all he did yeah
didn't do anything i think
it's like less than 10 seconds right he
looked at it
just moved it right okay ronaldo ahead
of his team's match
against hungary irritably set aside two
balls of coke then picked up a bottle of
water and said
agua the portuguese award for water
coca-cola shares had fallen 1.6
by the end of the press conference its
market value dropped 4 billion to 238
from 242 coca-cola an official sponsor
the uefa
euro 2020 tournament reportedly said in
a statement that everyone is entitled to
drink their preferences
and has differing tastes and needs
ronaldo has previously expressed
disapproval of coca-cola and other
unhealthy foods and beverages
his fitness routine is said to involve
eating six meals and taking five naps in
a typical
day and what a day awesome that's a
great schedule
so the power of ronaldo yeah how
powerful
is this what i think it just talks about
the power of
the personal brand the ronaldo's of the
world or the messies of the world or the
lebrons of the world
or even the jake pauls of the world all
eyes are on them
and if they do something it could move
markets and in this case we're all to
move the market by four billion dollars
in 10 seconds basically saying he's not
a coke guy so
you know who would be very proud of him
adam sandler and the water boy would be
very proud
bobby boucher would be very proud of
ronaldo right now
i i think this is a little overplayed i
you know
basically do you think four billion
dollars is overplayed okay
what is coke worth 242.
uh now 238. correct that's exactly right
and their high for the year was 257.
stock's at 54 right now give or take the
low for the year is 43 the high for the
year is 56.57
so basically you have a little blip that
could have been any given day
coke could have moved 4 billion dollars
just with market factors the
price of sugar things like this but i i
think what's it's interesting
we're pointing out is how markets can
move with influencers and i think that's
a story the story doesn't
co cost 4 billion and they're going to
get it back and coke is not just all
about soda they've been buying
into other drinks they own minute maid
you know they have dasani
they've they've been going not full bore
on soda for a while and they've been
taking caffeine out of
sodas they've been taking sugar out of
sodas they've been trying to follow that
you mean
they they caught more heat for vending
machines on campuses
with um economically priced you and i go
down to a vending machine a lobby of a
building it's a dollar dollar fifty for
a coke but they were vending machines at
50 cents
so the kids could get cokes with their
lunches and they're pointing out there's
a lot of sugar in that there's probably
something else you want
you know you know adolescent developing
kids to be having before they go back in
the classroom
and so the story here is that
influencers now
really move markets that's the headline
not that koch lost four billion in one
day that they're going to get back
in the next another sidebar here
power the influencer now i agree
i think uh something just this might be
a good little case study
on inflation and uh like a can of coke
used to be 50 cents
now it's a dollar fifty and now they're
now they're keeping the price the same
size
but they're but the same price but
they're basically
making the cans smaller have you noticed
these smaller coke cans
uh it's just it's just interesting that
they're all sort of around the same
price but
uh the sizes are getting smaller no the
greater the greater headline
you know if i was at forbes or some
place my headline you know what my
headline would have been on this
what's that and it says you know
influencer marketing confirmed
as coke stock moves when cristiano
ronaldo
you know touches two bottles in us in a
certain way and it's for everyone that
says
gosh why do you pay the kardashians for
a tweet you know fifty thousand dollars
for a tweet and then a backup tweet and
a retweet
it's fifty thousand here's your package
here's your rate card why do they pay
instagram influencers this i mean why is
all this happening the reason it's
happening because
influencers move markets and make
products
move that's the story here okay
i think the story here is that he takes
five naps a day that's pretty gangster
that's uh
i think everybody would want that but i
mean
he's killing it by the way simple as
that yeah he's killing it he does one ad
gets nine million views i mean people
are paying them left and right to just
do ads this guy's making so much money
it's not even funny i mean
look is there this guy's where is he on
your list of like just
the the most alpha males out there studs
soccer player best of all time he's a
good looking where is he on the list how
many balloons
are in the world he's up there
sam sam how many balloon diors has uh
cristiano ronaldo won i don't know the
answer
uh i would say nine or ten uh
i don't think it's nine or ten i think
it was three or four i thought he and
messi won like
eight of the last ten or something was
that like a trick question what are we
trying to do right there no no that's
five
he's got five just so that's that's like
that's like the mvp
of the world of soccer it's five and so
he's not just an alpha male
this guy is a tiger we can't hear you
just so you know you're muted we can't
hear you
yeah go ahead he has his own museum
hotels
it's beautiful but what he has done also
in business
yeah but the question is does he have
the statue that uh
uh uh james corden made for
beckham because the staff i mean beckham
has the greatest statue of all time i
don't know if you guys seen that
chin have you seen the pull this up
pull up the statue with david beckham
statue james corden you guys never seen
this before it's hilarious
he pulled a trick on him he says so the
day the opening of the statue
cordon brings them out to say you guys
have to see the spoof just go to images
because you can't play the video
uh uh he does he makes this statue
and he says uh brings him out he says
look we're so excited about it look at
his arms how long it is the fake one
hilarious fake statue look at that arms
are long he says
and and the artist who is uh the
comedian who is acting like the artist
is mars gibrani
and he's going talking to him say we
spend some because your arms are long we
wanted to give you a
width because you have so much power on
your chin you have such a powerful chin
he said i don't have a chin that big now
go on the butt side go in the back
go in the back go butt type and butt
great hair type and butt
okay let's just see if they show it or
not there's he says i don't have a butt
that big
he says you have a perfect butt so we
wanted to really highlight out
he's thick t-h-i-c-c
see i don't think ronaldo has a statue
like that but ronaldo is a legend and
when he does sponsorships people maybe
that comes
quick quick shout out to um quick shout
out to clay smith whose
great grandma just passed away she had
17 grand
uh great grandkids and uh you know want
to give a shout out to
clay smith's great grandma who just
passed away that's his statue
and by the way what's this statue that
has got to be that has got to be worse
that's got to be the worst statue i've
ever seen in my life i would be so
offended if i would say
ronaldo before and after it looks like
like two sides have been put together
before and after what are you talking
about braces or which one yeah yeah it's
like
if you put your hand over each side of
the statue did i click on the first one
you're saying he wasn't good-looking at
one point i'm just saying you know
everyone has to go through an ugly phase
even ronaldo was kind of
go go down kai go down the red shirt
right there boom
yeah i mean you know clearly he's
looking better these days
so can we see your before and after
is there a picture of you i'm not trying
to compete with ronaldo but
homie's done well for himself what a
picture you guys know we're being a
professional
shot by the way all of your 19 female
that were following you the ladies that
were following
they left out right because you're so
offended you offended the
ronaldo right okay so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye